hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play Windland now
this is a game that was made pretty much
revolving around the oculus rift and not
in a horror sense and not in like that
chicken sense this one actually is
supposed to be pretty intense so we're
gonna start playing oh hello yeah Wow
look at that this originally had
Minecraft placeholder graphics as far as
I know but right now it is a game that
is all about movement and that movement
is gauged by doing this oh sorry sorry
everybody I missed my target oops nope
OOP ah oh god that's so weird
and then you just shoot your grappling
hook over and you start flying and it's
awesome ah han-pan everybody hang on I
got it again
ah god damn cables everywhere oh it's an
AI Bearcat guy here got friggin cables
god dammit cables I'll try to have fun
let's show everybody what a cool game
this is dang okay there we go alright
god damn cables hog hate you I've caught
you to die anyway now that the cable
crushes are you now that the goddammit
Oh Oh be friends right hey Ezra say hey
my god I really should have figured all
this out before I started recording this
is so unprofessional of me oh well I
tried out of a magical adventure here oh
hey everybody how you doing let's have
some fun er sorry I've been trying to
get this to work up and we okay now that
the crisis is over I can finally get
adjusted here to where I'm actually
enjoying myself and look at this look at
it look at it is some all now I'm gonna
love it hmm ah come on OOP ah come on
OOP oh I get it
oh oh come on I was gonna make it I was
gonna be able to get out of that you
didn't know
alright fine let's go somewhere else
okay voices OOP yeah oh oh did I get it
[ __ ] ah whoa
god this is so cool Oh Oh No [ __ ] bang
oh I didn't respond oh it's so weird oh
god it's so cool the oculus rift is just
beautiful with it oh my god it's amazing
hey go round oh I made it
alright come on come on up up up up up
up push so cool yeah I got it oh I got
dragged back I got okay
oesn't that wasn't falling down I was
falling down into a little small pit not
an endless bit of death
God how could you not love it's okay so
there's other things that you can do I
think you know I don't remember how to
do them but all I know is that you can
do this and that's what's cool look at
it go
look at it go look at it go oh I feel
like I'm in attack on Titan and I'm
about to fight a Titan of fighting you
you know what a mess I'm about to kill
it dad but who are you
who LRU huh will you do it over here huh
ain't you just the prettiest thing I
ever seen huh I'm gonna go climb that is
my destiny
just like ass with catching pokémon mind
climbing stuff and then falling down
whoo oh wow yeah oh god it's so much fun
it doesn't it probably doesn't translate
as much to you guys but it's so cool to
see
I love the oculus rift I actually
ordered the UH the second dev kit for
the oculus rift is coming out - what the
hell what was that could I just fart all
over the place anyway the second dev kit
for the oculus rift is coming out soon
and all these gonna be risky oh let's do
it mister
yeah yeah Oh get it get something back
Mack Mack Mack that's all God who did
rub make it yeah that's the stuff
director go left left left left
oh goodness gravy what is that is that I
don't know what that is but it's cool
okay whoop Dee oh this is a bad move
make it make it make it make it
[ __ ] yeah
yeah okay that didn't work out so
apparently this game would be a lot
cooler if I could actually do something
with it and that's not a testament to
the game that's a testament to my skill
I can't exactly show you guys I don't
know what they are doing myself it
doesn't matter
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh ah why I was
doing fine did I fall and break my legs
is that what you did that I you thought
that I was doing why I didn't get it at
all
I very much do not get that ha ha ha I
got it yes I'm getting the hang of this
now not that I didn't have the hang of
it before but I was just much much
badder sure oh my god how do I get up it
ah
Claude Claude what get up yup get up
there we go okay good
yeah yeah I got it OOP oh absolutely
oh look at me I'm a professional where
do I go from here only up oh oh oh
gotcha it's like some elasticity to does
it'll come in
but not all it does holy crap
back it up Oh get up Oh dad come on yes
yeah I'm almost on top of the world
oh right this is so cool god that's cool
ought to get that I'm gonna get that Oh
angle it oh I got it yes oh my god it's
so cool oh oh wow big puff of smoke hoop
and I jump all big this I'm gonna get up
on that tree I'm gonna get on that tree
first I'm gonna get on that thing and
that Bush climb up on the bush climb up
on the tree
don't forget it Ariel get it get it I'm
gonna get up on the big tree aha what
that is anything cool bah bah toe
oh yeah
got it whoo ha ha not miss Bob no gosh
what all right
nope didn't I get this no I failed
Oh pathetic Oh Bret no doc you're
shooting it yeah I see that
I wanna get it ya know
there we go cool
get up it ah nope
okay
yeah ah I did it finally I think I'm on
the highest point I could have possibly
gotten to god that is cool look at all
that oh my god it's so cool
now I'm gonna jump off it oh my god
whoopty and I'm good
oh nothing good Oh falling to my death
and me who's Issa how my spine okay so
anyway that was Windland that was just a
ridiculous amount of fun for me guys I
hope you guys got some partial enjoyment
out of it through me maybe I don't know
this is really fun it was just weird cuz
the oculus rift is so good at giving the
immersive experience that like as you're
moving it really felt like I was moving
he was very messing with my head anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next week bye bye
close one
hoop but who put it